Hey Ken! Good to see ya!
Open the door.
Heey!
Whoa, hey Mark!
- How's it going?
You, ah, haven't returned any of my calls.
Just had a new number when I moved out of town.
- Ah cool! Wanna hang out?
Aah..
Well, not now is a good time, Mark.
Why not?
There's ... I got, I got some things.
Some things going on and, ah
Euhm things, like, things I can help out with?
No! Ah, this ...
Please!
Naw, come on, I'm coming in, allright!
Could I come in?
Well, not now is a good time, Mark.
Oh, yeah! No, no.
Got some ... some family things going on.
Right. No, I understand that! Anything I could help out with, maybe?
No, it's family, family.
- Right, family comes first anytime.
And we're like, brothers, you and I.
It's really good to see you, you know.
Yeah I know, it's good to see you.
So since, ah, I still have your number
I'll give you a call and let you know!
So, see ya later Mark! Okay? Bye.
- Euhm, Ken? Ken, please. Ken, lemme in ...
Ken, lemme in! Lemme in, Ken!
Hey Ken!
- Hey Mark.
Let me in, if that's okay?
- No, I can't.
I can't, Mark. Can't.
Hey Ken!
How you doing?
Oh, it's good to see you again!
It's been so long!
Wait, how did you get in?
You were just outside!
I know, now that I'm in here now,
we're gonna be playing so many fun games together, and having such a great time
all day every day, playing games, you and me!
Buddies! You want that, don't cha?
We're gonna have so much fun!
See? I told ya we'd be playing games together.
Together forever!
Best friends forever.
Stay toasty, my friends.